You are so beautiful.
I got accepted to Boston University.
I'm so proud of you.
Why do you care, you won't be around to see it anyway.
My mama had been the sun to me and Mr. Church, he was like the moon:...
...cool, calm and always there.
What's gonna happen now?
I think you should call Boston University...
...and tell them that Charlotte Brooks will be attending.
Come on Charlie, you can't go living with your cook forever.
My cook?
Richard set aside enough money for Mama to live six months.
Do you know who paid all of our bills all those years after that?
Mr. Church.
He saved us.
Do you have a place to stay?
She lives with me.
You gave me the most important thing life can offer.